the holding of this association council
was eagerly awaited and allowed us to
mark the renewal of
institutional relations between the
european union and morocco,
thus opening the way to the revival of
our privileged relationship and our
euro-moroccan partnership
opportunities to share the  The proximity between
the European Union and Morocco is very
strong and we will continue to work
together to pursue common objectives
, whether in terms of
security, the development of renewable
energies,
socio-economic reforms or education,
mobility and migration  is
among these challenges are not the only ones and
we were convinced that we can transform these
challenges into opportunities through
reinforced and balanced cooperation we
were discussing very frank and very
constructive positive they allowed us to
reiterate our commitment to
strengthening the partnership but
also and above all our determination
to breathe new life into this
part  enariat
it's been
almost four years since we
held an association council meeting, a period
which was a test for our partnership and
which showed the resilience, ambition
and determination to defend the
different dimensions of this partnership
of  pass from side to side